okay now Ecclesiastes 9: 5-6 I hope I'm
not putting you guys asleep boring you
right without numbers increase with me
they decrease Ah that's just me man just
as okay Ecclesiastes 9: 5-6 the question
here for the living know that they shall
die but the dead know not anything
neither have they any more a reward for
the memory of them is forgotten also
their love and their hatred and their
Envy is now perished neither have they
anymore a portion forever and any that
is done under the sun now Ecclesiastes
9:
5-6 Ecclesiastes 9: 5-6 is often quoted
by those who believe that when you die
you cease to exist see the debt know
nothing they perish so how do we answer
that are we ready Ecclesiastes 9 veres
5-6 this is often quoted by Joe's
Witnesses and others to show see when
you die you perish you cease to exist
you know nothing how do we answer that
are we ready for the
answer are we ready for the
answer here's the
answer this is why you have to
understand what's known as literary
genre the type of book what kind of book
it is and the theme of the book so now
guys here's how you're going to learn
how to interpret the Bible if you don't
listen you're not going to get the
answer if you don't listen you're not
going to get the answer Ecclesiastes is
wisdom literature but it's a specific
type of wisdom literature if you start
at chapter one the theme of Ecclesiastes
is the futility the
foolishness the despair of Human
Experience human observation in other
words it's a book about human secularism
in other words what Solomon is telling
us here is the
result of knowledge acquired by Human
Experience human observation the result
is Vanity foolishness futility and
despair Proverbs is giving you God's
wisdom here is the wisdom of God by
which you are to live and understand the
world Ecclesiastes is giving you human
wisdom and the futility of human
knowledge Human Experience human wisdom
because if all you have is human
observation
then you cannot answer the big questions
of
life you understand what I'm getting
at Ecclesiastes is not giving you in
every case God's perspective he's giving
you the perspective of the human
Observer on earth when he looks at the
world and see how the world is run and
sees the fate of human beings and
animals the conclusion is everything is
a waste everything is vain everything is
Vanity everything is despair there's no
hope isn't that atheism isn't that
secular humanism do you not have atheist
saying that at the end of the day there
is no meaning to life life is
meaningless that's what he's showing you
he's not telling you that the debt
perish and know nothing he's telling you
that's our observation because apart
from God apart from CH Christ telling us
there's light beyond the grave all we
see is people die perish and they're no
more end of story
kaput nihilism exactly so if you don't
understand the purpose of Ecclesiastes
you're going to get confused Solomon is
telling you note the difference between
human wisdom and divine revelation human
human wisdom will only lead to chaos
futility and despair it can't answer
these big questions that's why you need
God and you need Revelation from God let
me prove to you that's Solomon's Point
Ecclesiastes 3: 19-
21 Ecclesiastes 3: 19- 21 now watch here
it if you don't understand how to
interpret Solomon you're going to think
he's contradicting himself notice
Ecclesiastes 3: 19- 21 pay attention for
that which follow the sons of man befall
of beasts the same fate animals and
humans even one thing befall of them all
as the one dieth so dieth the other see
humans and animals die so what advantage
is there in being a human notice what
he's saying humans die like animals die
animals die like humans die so what
advantage is there in being a human in
fact from a human
perspective it's more advantageous to be
a dog because you have dogs who are
treated better than
humans right yay they have all one
breath one spirit so man hath no
preeminence over a beast do you believe
that man is not better than an animal is
that what God Said No that's not what
God
Said for all is
Vanity there is no Vantage in being a
human over being a dog cuz like the dog
you die and some dogs live lavishly
better than humans just ask theill and
their dogs and how they're pampered all
go onto one place and all are of the
dust and all turn to dust again now
notice verse 21 thank you Michael La God
bless you let's post 21 one more
time Ecclesiastes 3:21 God bless you
brother who knoweth the spirit of man
goeth upward do you know whether when a
man's Spirit when a man dies goes up to
God and whether the spirit of the Beast
goes down to the Earth can anyone answer
that without god without
Revelation without Jesus making it known
to us by a spirit in his revealed word
do you know whether the spirit of an
animal goes down and perishes or returns
to God and whether the spirit of man
goes to God or not can you answer that
question can you answer that
question without
revelation without the scriptures
without god making it known do you know
the answer to
that that's his point thank you brother
for the Super Chat so but now let me
tell you after he
concludes his discussion of the futility
the vanity the despair of Human
Experience human observation of nihilism
atheism secularism agnosticism which
cannot answer these big questions notice
how he concludes God bless you Antonio
thank you brother remember what he said
in ecclesiast 3:21 who knows whether the
spirit of man goes up but wait look what
he says in Ecclesiastes
12:7 seems like he's contradicting
himself Ecclesiastes
12:7 notice now when he wants the end of
discussion then shall dust return to the
Earth as it was and the spirit shall
return unto God who gave it but wait
Solomon in 3:21 you're wondering does it
go up or not but now at the end you're
saying it definitely goes back to God
how did you know that did you contradict
yourself didn't you just say in 3:21 who
knows whether it goes
up but now you say it does go to God
because now he's talking about God's
revelation not human observation
in other words what's the purpose of
Ecclesiastes
12 let me explain to you see if you
don't understand why the books of the
Bible were given then you're going to
get confused Ecclesiastes 12 I'm sorry
Ecclesiastes was given from God to show
you here is the end result of Human
Experience human observation a life
apart from God and his wisdom you end up
with nihilism you see the futility the
vanity the despair that atheism creates
that agnosticism creates
despair
confusion vanity loneliness misery
because they can't answer life's big
questions and so what does Solomon say
forget Human Experience forget human
observation because that's going to
destroy any hope you have turn back to
God and his word and trust in him
because now notice Ecclesiastes 12: 12-
14 Ecclesiastes 12 verses 12-
14 guys now read with me how he
concludes Ecclesiastes how he concludes
Ecclesiastes and further by these my son
be admonished let me now admonish you
let me tell you now what the purpose of
your life is let me tell you now what
brings true meaning to life you want to
know the purpose and meaning life here
it is my son forget human observation
forget Human Experience because I've
been there done that and will lead you
to misery so here's the purpose of life
my
son of making many books there's no end
you're going to keep writing and
debating and arguing that's never going
to end and a much study is awareness of
the flesh you'll never ever end end
writing discussing
studying and debating that never ends
and I know as an
apologist I'll say one thing 20 people
will produce responses to it it never
ends so then what's the goal Christian
what's the purpose of your life to keep
writing books reading books and debating
and refuting and responding no that's
not the purpose here's the purpose let
us hear the conclusion of the whole
matter here's the conclusion fear
God and keep his Commandments for this
is the whole duty of man for God will
bring every work into judgment and every
single s secret thing whether it be good
or whether it be evil that's the
conclusion you see what he
says you understand what he
says that's the
conclusion in other words folks it's not
about debating it's not about arguing
it's not about refuting like truth
Defenders who come on my Facebook page
and call people slimy filthy
degenerates and has to argue with
everyone and his mother and their
brother right it's not about that you
know what it's about knowing god
enjoying God trusting in God loving God
and obeying him and what what are my
goals for my sessions what did I just
say let me repeat what I've been saying
like a broken record the the purpose of
my sessions is to be used of the holy
spirit for us to plung the depth of
scripture the meat of scripture to
understand scripture with greater
understanding so we can fall more in
love with God stand more in awe of God
obey God more follow Jesus more live for
him more passionately and be like
him haven't I said that over and over
again
that's why I tell you don't come to my
channel and debate me you're wasting
your time don't come to my channel and
argue with me you're wasting my time if
you want to debate set it up that's not
the purpose of my channel you have
sincere objections I'll answer them but
if you're setting me up with a question
that when I answer you bring up another
question that means you're not listening
you see the point
now because was there a wiser King than
Solomon who was filled with such such
wisdom of God who had 1,000 women 700
wives 300 concubines who knew the
futility of Human Experience human
observation living a life apart from
Revelation contrary to God's will and
you know what he says I've done it been
there done that seen it all tasted it
all and at the end
misery vanity
depression and so I returned to God and
His Commandments
okay let me show you what he says about
women let me show you what Solomon says
about women and if anyone was an
authority on women it's Solomon
Ecclesiastes
7:28 watch
here which yet my soul seeketh but I
find not I haven't found one man among a
thousand have I found meaning one good
man but a woman among all those have I
not found he goes among men I found one
man that was good good among a thousand
but to this day I haven't found one good
woman if anyone knew wom it's him 700
700 wives 300 concubines
Solomon you can write a book on
women and you're telling me all these
women that you enjoyed and you slept
with and none of them were righteous not
one not one
isn't it ironic he said a thousand among
a thousand men I found one cuz he had a
thousand women 700 wives 300 concubines
is that a coincidence he mentions a
thousand among a thousand men I found
one I had a thousand women none of them
were
good now wait does that mean God agrees
with
Solomon is this God's view that there is
no righteous woman no woman that is pure
and righteous then what do you do with
the mother of
Christ what do you do with the mother of
Christ what do you do with
Sarah what do you do with her what do
you do with
Sarah he's telling you from Human
observation and experience if I seek
women apart from God if I go after women
apart from God I'll end up in disaster
because every woman I'll find will be a
snare seeking to destroy me but if I see
God he will bring me that godly woman
now let's contrast what Solomon said
from God's perspective Proverbs
18:22 Proverbs
18:22 I know you woman got upset say
what man what you talking about here
Proverbs 18:22 he who finds a wife finds
a good thing and obtains favor from the
Lord oh that's a contradiction how can
finding a wife be favor from God when no
woman is good because you don't
understand the genre see my
point you don't understand the purpose
of Ecclesiastes Ecclesiastes is telling
you this is the conclusion of my human
experience with women the women I
sought none of them were good because
they were not from
God but if you see God for a woman he
will bring you that good woman and take
it as favor from God you see the
difference you see the difference now if
you don't understand eclesiastes you're
going to create contradictions left and
right so this is the beauty of our Bible
let me tell you why your Bible is
beautiful Majestic the Bible has a book
addressing everything if you want to
know what Ecclesiastes is this is the
result of nihilism atheism agnosticism
human observation Human Experience human
wisdom that's not based on Revelation
here's a conclusion misery disaster
despair heartache pain loss of hope so
now seek God and his wisdom that's
Proverbs seek God and his wisdom that's
the letters of Paul seek God's
revelation to see reality from God's
perspective to know what to do and not
to do to save yourself from harm
otherwise if you ignore God and his
wisdom Revelation and try to do it on
your own you're going to end up in
misery disaster depression heartache
pain despairing of life thank you Lisa
God bless you Sister